boris johnson standing down but not
leaving
still in office he says for weeks to
come until a new leader walks through
the number 10 door mps are worrying if
they can wait that long the last 48
hours his refusal to accept reality has
done a lot of damage um to
trust in the institution as a whole in
in parliament in conventions that we
have in the conservative party he has
lost the confidence of the party that's
absolutely apparent and therefore it's
not appropriate that we have anything
other than a proper caretaker
administration a new cabinet is in place
promising no surprises in the coming
weeks a bare-bones government facing so
many crises
the biggest war in europe for decades
skyrocketing bills stalling the economy
and a health service battling a
crippling covered backlog all pushing
the conservative party to move at speed
you could have the hustings over the
next couple of weeks the house rises in
two weeks time you've got two full
parliamentary weeks to have the hostings
at which point there could be two
candidates emerged there will be two
candidates that emerge and they're the
two that go before the membership the
question then is whether the second
place candidate if they're really well
behind the first place candidate will
decide to step aside
a former prime minister used to party
insurrection urging haste too
in a damning letter sir john major wrote
the proposal for the prime minister to
remain in office is unwise and may be
unsustainable some will argue his new
cabinet will restrain him i merely note
that his previous cabinet did not or
could not do so
the bond of trust between boris johnson
and the conservative party is now
fundamentally broken yet he remains in
office for weeks if not months
jostling to succeed him has already
begun but the manner of his downfall
could create a whiplash that results in
a very different successor who takes the
country in a new direction
an mp who voted remain and has never
served in government tom tugan hat
immediately endorsed by the moderate
wing of the party it's very likely that
you're gonna run look i i you know i
can't give you a straight answer until
i've actually spoken to people that i
know whether i've got the numbers and i
know i've got the support but it's not a
secret that i've been thinking about
this and i've been talking to people
about the sort of things that the
country needs you know the
rebirth of trust the renewal of the
economy and
and the restart you know clean restart
that we all need
there will be many contenders to be the
next prime minister but leadership
contests deepen divisions and expose
weakness in a party that has already
spent months tearing itself apart sam
coates sky news westminster
does boris johnson need to go now